(burbling electronic noise)
- (Using Russian accent)
Where are the microfilms?
Stealing images of civilian infrastructure
is punishable by execution.
But if you cooperate, maybe
we can reduce your sentence
to a few
anguishable hours with yours truly.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- Lies!
This isn't some American fondue party.
This is KGB black site
for political prisoners
where you'll be tortured
until you beg for death.
Now for the genital extraction.
- Wait, wait, wait. What are you doing?
- (Using normal accent) Can
you please stay in character?
Please?
- How are we supposed to have sex if you
extract my genitals?
- I don't know! I was just going to
work my way up to it
and then, like, do
something sexy with 'em.
- Ahhhh!
Okay.
- [Woman] Jesus, you have no imagination.
- Alright.
- [Woman] Okay, okay, okay.
- Alright, alright.
- (In Russian accent) Okay.
Now
for the genital extraction.
- Wait, wait. Give me a sec.
- What is your problem?
- I feel ridiculous
here. Can we do something
at least semi-realistic, please?
- Like realistic, like
how? Like having, you know,
sex in a Marriott with room service?
We've done that.
- So I'm a square because I
don't want to get castrated
in some Soviet gulag?
- No. No.
You're square because you come
to the table with zero ideas.
- I come up with ideas all the time.
- Like what?
- Like...
Okay, what if you were...?
- Come on!
- Listen, how about we do
something in our own skins
in a scenario that's,
like, vaguely plausible?
Where you don't cut my dick off?
- In our own skins?
- Yeah.
- Fine.
- [Man] Yeah?
- Yeah. Fine.
- [Man] Okay!
- Can I keep my accent though?
I kinda like it.
- I'd prefer not, but...
- Okay. Fine.
- Okay.
(electronic tones)
- Are we at the gynecologist?
- I know.
- Why are we here?
- [Doctor] Alright, Kat.
We are ready for your
full body examination.
- My gynecologist?
- You said you were open
to something more grounded,
so I thought...
- Yeah, grounded as in like
experimenting in a safe space.
Not have a threesome with someone we know
that, like, threatens our marriage.
- She doesn't even live here anymore.
- Since when?
- Since she moved to Pennsylvania
to be closer with her family.
Oh, come on.
You're never going to see her again.
What does this matter?
- It matters because
she's my gynecologist.
She's a trusted figure in my life.
She's been examining me for five years.
She knows my pregnancy.
- She knows you in a way that
only another woman could know!
- Do not. Stop that.
- I'm sorry.
- (Growls) Okay.
- I'm getting kind of tired.
Can we just rain call this please?
Tomorrow?
- I have Pilates tomorrow.
- Hey. I'm not trying
to be difficult, okay?
- (Using Russian accent) Why
can't we go back to Russia?
- (Laughs)
- I miss it.
(In normal accent) You wanna try one more?
(electronic tones)
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Wait a minute.
That's your flower jersey.
- Yeah.
- Wait, when is this?
- It's moving day.
Five years ago.
- Wait.
I sprained my wrist?
- Yeah. On the U-Haul.
- Ohhh.
- No, no, no, no.
- Yes!
(both laughing)
- What?
What?
- I don't know.
Isn't this sort of weird?
Like, we've already done this before.
- So?
- So I thought the point was to, like,
try something new.
- The point is to enjoy ourselves.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
Just think of it, like, we're
playing our greatest hits.
- This is our best hits?
The shitbox apartment in Glendale?
- Well, I have my pre-baby tits.
And you have the hairline
of a 25-year-old.
So, I don't think it
gets better than that.
- Oh God, though, how does that sentence
not depress you?
What is it just...
It's all downhill from this moment?
- I don't want to have a
philosophical discussion.
I just want to have sex.
- Okay.
- Please?
- That's good, right?
- Yeah. Of course.
- Okay.
♫ Why don't you do what you
do what you do what you do?
(upbeat '50s style rock
mixed with sex noises)
♫ Darling, why do you do what you do?